hey guys Tim Ferriss Alton's 4-hour
workweek for our what not here this is
Molly
my little pup and I'm gonna show you one
of the first prerequisite skills that I
trained with her and that is attention
so if you can't get your dog's attention
with their eyes it's very hard if they
don't check in to get them to follow
other commands and it's very simple to
train this I used a quicker these costs
about 99 cents like that and then I used
treats and you got a tip with 20s as one
of my trainers said it's a crowded bar
don't tip a single so I use origin Ori
je and a free run duck or one of these
other treats whole prey diet as they say
this is how you train it's very simple
use the clicker to mark a specific time
that correlates to the action you want
to reward and so the way you do this as
you can see her eyes around the tree and
then you do this to the face out she
looked at me just for a split second and
then I give her the treat and this
transferred always check in and you'll
see as we get a little bit more advanced
this is normal so she just looked at me
she's obviously done this before
right it's it's surprising how quickly
you can train a dog maybe five to ten
minutes let's start to get it then you
can do things like alright so I've
trained her to leave it and then check
in with me and this is very helpful not
only for getting her to follow basic
obedience but to avoid eating toxic
things chasing deer for instance this
happened yesterday and so on and that is
it so the prerequisite skill the meta
skill over all the others so that you
might want to teach your dog is
attention and this is one click very
simple way to do thanks so much for
watching guys and be sure to consider
signing up for my email newsletter by
clicking on email newsletter because I
share private q and A's exclusive
content awesome things like five bullet
Friday's which is the five coolest
things I've discovered in a given week
exclusively via email and that's for the
die hard that's for the people who
really want the main line of usefulness
and how-to and to really ride along with
me as I learn and discover the most you
well things that I find so check it out
email newsletter click on it and please
let me know what you would like more of
in terms of video in terms of audio I
will try to make it for you so let me
know in the comments and thank you again
for watching